coming off a five-inning stint against
those uh detroit tigers only allowed the
one hit he walked three and struck out
five now he leads the league and walk
he's walked 33 11 of those runs have
come around to score via the walk so you
know try and be aggressive and make him
put it in play
tied him up with a good fastball and
strikes him up
and mckenzie is pumped to start this one
well any time
you know a team roughed you up the last
time you want to go back and you want
your opportunity so he takes him three
pitches on our nissan pitch tracker a
couple of sliders a high fastball he
gets the strikeout
there's the ball lying to deep left
field
and
ramirez with a fine running catch on the
warning track
they could take a an extra base hit away
from johann montana the white sox go in
order the indians are coming to back
carlos were done on for the ninth start
he's looking for his sixth win as era of
129 the rest of the numbers are just
staggering left-handers don't even need
to bring up a bat carlos rodon
delivers and cesar jumps on the first
pitch drives it to deep left field and
it is off the top of the wall
he'll roll into second base with a
lead-off double
and just missed hitting one out of here
they're saying that's a home run out in
the seats and i bet that ball got over
that yellow line
and i'm sure tito is going to challenge
it so let's get it we'll get another
look at it don't miss his fastball baby
oh yeah
that's a home run for sure yeah quick
decision it sure is that ball is certain
absolutely home run number seven for
cesar hernandez ahmed rosario
there's a ball crushed deep left field
hello bleachers
boom
two-nothing cleveland on back to back
home runs oh did he find the barrel
there is no mercy here for rhoda they
know what he did to him in april
and they are coming out a swinging baby
that'll be the third home run for um ed
rosario and that you didn't have to
worry about
going to a replay machine that was well
back over the fence
slow chopper i don't know jose hurries
and he got it what a play
well that's how you do it uh brayu
didn't get a good jump out of the box
but ramirez came in and he didn't rush
he feels it cleanly you know you got to
get rid of it quickly and it's right on
the money a beautiful play to get him by
a half a step on the way down
but it's an out and now zach collins
usually very patient stands in against
mckenzie
faces loaded one out
collins down the line that's a fair ball
for zach mercedes is home eaton's gonna
tie the game and the socks are back even
zach collins drives in three as the ball
stuck on the right side
and one more run comes in with garcia
how about that everybody's looking
around and the third run comes home the
sox have taken the lead nice aggressive
heads up base running joe mcewing
probably sending leori when he realized
that hernandez just dropped the ball so
they're gonna throw to first base here
thinking they can catch tim oh now they
got him let's see what zach does from
third zach collins watching this tim
pointing at him here comes zach on his
way to the plate and zach came around to
score i think zach got there in time
before tim got tagged out tim was
directing traffic between first and
second to wave zach in and the sox got a
fourth run out of the deal carlos
hernandez led off the first with a homer
to left the pit swung on he hits it deep
to left field again this ball is going
gone
cesar hernandez with a pair of solo
homers to left off carlos rodon
and it's a 4-3 ball game and cesar
hernandez his first
two homer game ever i want to show it uh
when we come back for
our second game there he goes and
strikes out mercedes that's four k's now
for mckenzie
go two swing and a miss hot cheddar oh
my
he is barking screaming at the home
plate umpire he didn't swing the bat you
i was gonna say he didn't swing at that
pitch why is he yelling at the um
there you go
and now the one-two offering
swinging in a miss he went fishing came
up empty and mckenzie strikes out the
side see if you can zero in find a gap
his best stroke seems like rick when he
goes to right center field
there it is
back eating it's over his head and a
one-hop defense flying around third here
comes josh naylor
here's the throw to the plate he is safe
the indians have tied the game
you chang delivering with a ringing rbi
double to right field
memorial day doubleheader here in
cleveland where the indians and white
sox are tied at four
yes sir
fastball painted
seven strikeouts for tristan mckenzie
and that is five in a row
swing and a miss hey struck him out
that's eight k's for mackenzie who's
going through this lineup for like a hot
knife through butter
oh he didn't miss that time
nine strikeouts for mckenzie
including the last seven batters in a
row you've got to learn to read pictures
as well and no moves and know what their
tendencies are
and know what running counts are there
he goes
swinging a miss throw down not even
close
the only question was would he slide
into left field man he went in with a
full head of steam well when he gets it
rolling he's a tall guy and he's got a
slide earlier because you know that this
these infields watch that's a nice job
by hernandez just to swing and keep the
catcher back behind the plate i wonder
if ramirez is going here
he does this is a ground ball to
madrigal it's second base and rodon gets
out of trouble here in the fifth inning
sox bypass jose ramirez and pay it off
we're tied at four
tristan mckenzie an incredible
performance by striking out seven
consecutive batters
equaling the franchise record last
achieved by corey kluber the 3-2 is
strike to recall
he's done it
tristan mckenzie has struck out eight
straight
a new franchise record for the cleveland
indians in a franchise
that is littered with great names like
rap and robert bob feller
bob lemon sudden sam mcdowell louis
theon it's now tristan mckenzie
all alone in the record book with eight
straight strikeouts in the ball game 3-2
again
on the ground second base of brayu
running and he slides in safely the flip
went over the bag and the sox take the
lead so abreu on his way to second saves
the day
breaks up a surefire double play and the
sox have the advantage
first and third two down
and the one-two pitch is a broken back
ground ball to short
tim anderson has to hurry didn't get it
there in time and the indians have tied
the ball game up
bradley zimmer shot out of a cannon
beats it out and josh naylor scores the
tying run
top of the eighth inning an extra inning
in a seven inning doubleheader game
jose lines it to left field this is
caught on a slide by ramirez hamilton
scores and it's a sac fly for jose abreu
and he gets the job done against karen
check for a white sox lead
it's a fastball eaton tattoos it to
right field naylor watches it go it's
gone
bring him both home
eight five
first two hit game for adam eaton in 20
days
and they're both for extra bases
there is some magic in this team
the white sox are an out away from a win
it's now eight to six the pitch swing
and a miss and the white sox win their
first
extra innings game of the season